[Music]
penny mckinnon didn't set out to conquer
the world of food she began her career
making salads in her tiny home kitchen
and delivering them to happy customers
by bicycle but that led to a
self-published cookbook that became a
cult sensation in her native australia
and then came three more including her
latest that shows us how to turn produce
from our local market into amazing asian
creations
so i mean what i love is like really
focusing on everyday vegetables walk
through hedy mckinnon's local farmers
market what are we looking for we're
looking for broccoli okay and you get a
feast for the eyes now that's a good
piece of broccoli since for the soul
we still have peaches i think i'm gonna
get some peaches and a feeling that even
in the heart of brooklyn you can taste a
bit of her ancestral homeland
this food writer and self-described home
cook wants to show people the basics of
chinese and asian cooking without all
the fuss
it's the basis of her latest cookbook to
asia with love
and the reason we're sharing a seed at
the table when we ate my mum would call
us to the table with the words sick farm
sick fun sick farms eat rice eat rice
it's like that in many asian cultures
the rice is the sacred ingredient on the
table and at her mom's table precision
was key so you have to have a good
command of your chopsticks and we would
eat every single rice kernel before we
left the table so how am i doing you're
doing okay dig in there
michelle
and dig in we did to a traditional
cantonese banquet based on her mother's
recipes and mckinnon's vegetarian habit
some of these things are exactly how my
mum would make like this is actually my
mum's recipe the mapo tofu the vegan
version you know the original version
has the ground pork so my mum actually
started helping me veganize or
vegetarianize
the dishes that she knew i loved the
potato and chive omelette was naturally
vegetarian anyway it was one of her
quick meals growing up and it's so
comforting potatoes and eggs that run
through a lot of cultures and it's like
scrambled eggs and hashbrowns basically
right there is also a japanese-inspired
miso roasted eggplant stir-fried
potatoes with salt and vinegar a nod to
british chips green beans dressed with
fermented soy soybeans my youngest
actually says i want to stop but i can't
when he eats those green beans every
mother's dream exactly
and another asian staple bok choy a dish
i call restaurant greens so yeah
beautiful by the way isn't it beautiful
and my mom taught me how to make it with
she puts a little bit of oil and sugar
in the water that you blanch it and it
just keeps the greenness so the vibrancy
of the color is really important the
other thing about these types of dishes
you know a reflection of me growing up
in two countries and
kind of bringing together those two
influences you know the third culture
that third culture notion came after
what mckinnon calls an identity crisis i
was born in sydney australia i
grew up being very much caught between
the two cultures you know at home my mom
built this very chinese household we
spoke cantonese at home we ate like this
every night we celebrated she lit
incense every morning at her altar to
pay respects to her elders and we
celebrated all the customs but as soon
as i left the front door i wanted to be
australian did you feel that sense of
shame almost yeah i didn't want people
to ever hear me speaking cantonese i
didn't even want to admit that i could
speak a different language until i
started cooking which was really only 10
years ago i really
fell into a career in food and it was
like reclaiming you know who i am
reclaiming my culture and so the recipes
here that you see before you are like me
saying i'm really proud of who i am and
as a mother that i can
bring that to my children mckinnon's
interest in food has taken her through
family community and neighborhood themes
of her popular cookbooks and articles
she's written over the last decade it
even led hong kong restaurant vida to
ask her to create a vegetarian menu they
didn't want a traditional chinese menu
but i got to do things like a soba
noodle salad with my ginger scallion oil
which is what i call my mother source it
was an incredible experience going there
and being asked to do that validating i
would assume i felt like it was impostor
syndrome when i was there because i was
in a kitchen training proper chefs i
don't call myself a chef i'm a home cook
i didn't go to cooking school or
anything but more importantly about that
trip wow it was incredible to go back to
the smells and the sounds that i
remember from childhood which drives her
desire for those outside the culture to
access it especially during a time that
has been fraught with hate crimes
against asian americans i had to go back
within myself and confront those
feelings
of having this book that says love and
then there's there's hate
so it's been a very interesting year to
release that book i could never have
known it resonated with so many people
and people felt comforted by the stories
and to me that's all i want
out of all the food and all the stories
that i create is for people to feel
that comfort yeah this is what i call an
umami bomb it's an umami the kind of
comfort that can only be created around
a table by blending the old with the new
there seems to be a bit of
rebelliousness
in some of these recipes yes
the dumpling chapter it's um i was very
proud of this michelle it's dumplings by
the season so the idea behind it is you
could go to the market whatever
vegetables are in season and you could
turn that into a dumpling anything you
want i was like yeah beetroot that could
go at a dumpling brussels sprouts that
could go on a dumpling i do a lot of
things like that which are not
traditional it is probably
my way of rebelling against the
tradition that my mum presented to me so
it's fun it's you yeah it's me
and i just wanted to show you oh you're
good
[Music]
[Laughter]
i was so impressed
here we go
there we
cheers
[Laughter]
and really she says it's her mission to
like teach folks it's
so easy i mean there are these these
quick and simple recipes that you can
follow that get you to the end result
that a lot of people think oh it's too
meaty asian food is too hard to make
it's so intimidating she says not so
it's the chopstick pea cheer
yeah you like that dude you did wow
very impressed with the chopsticks